some people raise concerns about there
not being enough studies about the
effects of 5g on the human body
is 5g safe
look uh i have a very simple answer
to to this question
as
we build
new capabilities such as 5g power is
going down
especially when you think about reducing
the number of base stations the
network's becoming more dense
so
as you do that the the power
becomes lower if you're radiated from
power radiated from the phone and from
the tower as you get closer to the tower
you don't need that much power to reach
the tower so as
as we move from 4g to 5g i think we see
a reduction in the amount of powers
required to close the radio link
now
also you have a number of organizations
the fcc for example has rigorous uh
programs which they do a lot of tests uh
to validate uh you know the safety of
those devices and i think we have
has been a model for other countries
also to adopt the same things
uh
cellular has been around for a number of
decades now uh i think smartphone is our
most beloved device uh today
and i i would argue
how it's difficult to answer those
questions because you
yeah but i'll argue that the data to
date have we seen in 3g and 4g
um
you know has uh shown that uh
a lot of the initial concerns were not
valid
we look at 5g even though it's new it's
just less power so we look at from
from a physics standpoint so from
physics from a biology perspective
there's a lot of evidence there's
studies
that show that it's not
uh dangerous that it is in fact safe
however the concern that people have is
when you scale technology exponentially
um
how would that change human civilization
i mean that doesn't apply to 5g that
applies to every technology how you said
smartphone is the most beloved device
but love
sometimes hurts
that's an impact on society we don't
know and and there's a little bit of
fear there's both excitement and fear
it's a great topic a conversation
actually so so let me give you my
perspective on this and you started to
see some things actually happening right
now so let me step back
and let's talk about the fact that we
are in a fully interconnected society
that when
when uh when you look of the situation
today we talk about smartphones uh
largest uh development platform uh so
much now of our life uh
we are connected to the smartphone and
as a result and we are all connected and
we're connected
and then we're building digital twins of
everything right so so when you look at
that picture when you look at the
picture of this connected society
you started to have
the following thoughts which i think are
very healthy which means in the same way
that in the physical world
you're entitled to some rights you have
obligations and there's a lot of
things that protect your your integrity
i think as a rule we're going to see the
society evolving so those things extend
to your digital being
of people and things and i think just
natural it's just natural
it's just a natural path and you started
to see things like that for example the
europeans has done
a lot in this area i'll say the
europeans probably ahead in the united
states and thinking about privacy laws
digital privacy's law most recent the
dma the digital markets act which i
think is a great thing i think we're
we believe there's incredible uh thought
in to enable
ability to regulate the digital market
so that there's innovation and
competitions and not not a single
company
can control all the data and then decide
you know uh
how things gonna be work on the digital
realm and even if we think about the
potential things like the meta versus
we're connecting physical and digital
spaces so i think it's a natural
evolution of course regulate regulation
and laws always follow technology but
but the fact that we're uh moving to our
interconnected society there's there's
no going back uh we are a fully
interconnected society but there is
opportunity uh to think about how the
digital to win uh
should peop people and government should
think about it so that we get the best
of a technology we doubt that any
downside yeah so when you say digital
twin that's one of the other things
you're excited about which is the
metaverse are basically building worlds
in the in the digital space and you have
to start to think about all the basic
human rights
that
transfer from our physical meat vehicles
out to the digital copies of ourselves
representations of ourselves it's really
important to think about the thing you
mentioned about regulators that has been
this is me speaking frustrating is like
you said they follow technology so
sometimes they don't get the technology
at all
so they're very clumsy in writing laws
that
censor that technology in interesting
ways they mean good but they can do a
lot of unintended damage now both it's a
dance it's a beautiful dance but i just
wish governments were better dance
partners i just see what they're kind of
writing now about regulating social
media and
platforms like youtube and it's just
really really clumsy they don't
understand how machine learning works i
recommend their systems work and i just
wish they kind of caught up a little
more because it's really important to be
great
at regulation
but also it's important to let companies
flourish and embrace this new wave of
technology that that weird dance i i'm
more and more learning looking at public
public policy how much
positive government can do and how much
clumsy negative it can do
unintentionally
just out of sheer incompetence or lack
of curiosity about tech
that's my rant about regulators
i think it's a valid point
as i said before i think the europeans
probably have a very good framework but
you know the way the way i'll oh think
about it we we depend on have the
ability to innovate we depend on the
free markets we depend on the ability to
create uh you know technology that uh
that would be disruptive
but at some time i think the tech
companies probably should spend time
helping governments understand helping
understand ahead of time so that they
can be better prepared
you